Here is my solution. We're using the dictionary as a cache. We're
going to use a and b as the key to this cache. So
I just made a variable here called key which is just the
tuple of a and b and in Python, you can use a tuple
as a key and a hash table. Not all hash tables work
this way, but the dictionaries built in the Python [INAUDIBLE] convenient. So
the first thing we do is to say, if key in cache
and if so r equals cache key. Which basically looks up that value
in the cache. If its not in the cache,
we run complex computation. We set cache key key to
equal r and then we return r. So let's see
how this, this runs. Okay, so if I were to
call cached computational. The inputs 5 and 3,. We see
the value 8 prints out.Okay? And it paused for half
a second but you'll just have to believe me. let's,
let's add some extra information here so we can see
how long it's taking to run. Okay, the first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to store in a variable called start time, the current
time. If you call time.time Using the time library here. This will return
the current time in seconds. That is just our starting point. Then we
will actually print our cache computation like what we did before and
then I will print how long it took to compute that. And so
what I am doing here is I say print and then I am
printing the string for the first computation took percent f seconds. Percent f
is just like percent s except its, we'll print a
number formatted a little bit better. And I'm going to print the
current time minus the start time which will basically give
us how many seconds this this computation took to run. So
let's give this a run. Okay, now we see the
first computation took. Just over half a second. And that makes
sense because we sleep for half a second and otherwise we're
just adding 2 numbers, which doesn't take very long at all.
Let's go ahead and run this a second time and see what happens
if we run it twice in a row. Okay, so I just copied
and pasted these lines and we're going to run them a second time. So
we're going to restart the start time and then we're going to run the
same computation again with different numbers. And we are going to print how
long it took to run. So let's give this a run. Okay, so
now we have printed out 2 things. We printed out the result both
times, the first time the computation took .5 seconds. And the second time
when we had a cache hit, when we ran through this
piece of code here. The computation took .000011 seconds. Which is
substantially faster. So if we had to run this computation a
lot. Let's say we're returning the front page of askichan and
we didn't want to do that database query over and over
again and we cached it, we could get a substantial speed
improvement. Now who knows how long it takes to actually run
the front page of askichan. We will get to that in
a bit. But this is the general algorithm, and you should
get familiar with you know, this algorithm because you'll be using it
a lot. You know, there's lots of different ways you can
cache things, lots of different types of caches and all sorts of
things, but the algorithm is always the same. If you'd like
to see if something's in the cache, if it is return it,
otherwise compute it, store it, return it. So, good job if
you got that and let's move along to a real world example.